hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones finale QA just
careful for spoilers from season 6 if
you haven't caught up yet a lot of
questions about Jon Snow's parentage how
he's gonna prove it and just in general
what the hell's going on with the last
two seasons if there's gonna be 13
episodes if there's gonna be a movie
after that so I tried to include all
that stuff so here we go first question
dr. Jim asks so how can John prove it I
assume you're talking about his
Targaryen blood there's a couple ways
but the only real legit way would be to
have a record of it in the Citadel it's
one thing for John to learn who his
parents are but it's a whole other thing
to prove it to the rest of the realm
maesters being like the closest thing
you have to lawyers the Citadel's
records aren't absolutely complete but
they almost have a record of everything
that's happened one of their tasks is to
document history so for instance
Daenerys his birth at Dragonstone was
recorded by the maesters so like even a
brand came back and told everyone in the
realm that John was part Targaryen he
showed them the vision they still might
not believe it so even if one of the
dragons cozies up to him that still
doesn't necessarily prove to the realm
that he's a Targaryen so there needs to
be a record and if there was a record of
it it would probably be somewhere buried
in the Citadel the problem with that is
there's been no evidence in the books
and no evidence on the TV show to prove
that there is a record of his birth and
who his parents are or that there was a
wedding in fact so it's possible that
Leone and Rhaegar were in love and they
got married on the side as was the
custom with Targaryen it's a long time
ago to take multiple wives but that's
another thing - that will require a
legal document to prove next question
Cameron asks who do you think is next on
Arya skill list let's say
Cersei in the Hound and she might leave
the Hound for last because it seems like
she cares about him the showrunners made
a really big deal about what a
cold-blooded murderer Arya has turned
into she baked a bunch of phrase into a
pie so she's stone cold but Sir she's in
the red keep so she's pretty safe for
the moment and she hasn't bumped into
the Hound yet but I do feel like given
the choice she would leave the Hound for
last because she actually cares about
him whereas she wants to see Circe's
head on a pike
next question Abbey asks I don't
understand how the dead cannot pass the
wall theory so you're asking about you
know like there were previous seasons
where dead bodies got reanimated
inside the Nights Watch they had to kill
and that's how they learned about the
whites so the clarification that the
director like the people behind the
episode gave is that dead bodies can
pass through the wall once they're past
the wall then they can be reanimated but
if under normal circumstances like the
night King isn't reanimating someone
himself like at hardhome where he just
immediately raised all those bodies
during that initial period there's
probably still time while the body is
dead but hasn't been reanimated while it
can pass through the wall so the other
teaser that Dan and Dave gave about
future seasons and in the night King
getting past the wall was that bit about
his army not being able to pass through
the wall but the wildling climbers being
able to get over it so we might see some
epic climbing montage it sounds like for
now based on the explanation the show
has given us the only way for the white
walkers to get past the wall is either
for them to bring it down completely or
to travel over it next question and
creative asks where's ghost
where's John's direwolf yes so many
people were like where's ghost they
basically said that because of the the
giant that affects for it were so
difficult to do they had to choose
between doing it and doing ghost in the
last two episodes I know it sucks and it
seems like they have unlimited money but
it actually does take a lot of work to
do the effects for Ghost and they just
said it was too crazy to try and do
ghost and the giant at the same time
next question Alicia asks anybody know
when season seven is gonna air well
unless they tell us different I would
assume about the same time although this
season season six was a little bit late
so imagine closer to the beginning of
April and just to clarify so they said
there's 13 hours of television left
which is basically 13 episodes across
two seasons making season seven about
seven episodes in the last season six
episodes but they also said 75 hours
total 73 we'll call it for now like
that's me paraphrasing what they said
meaning that if we get a six episode
season eight there's still two hours
left over so what can you think of that
lasts for two hours well they could do a
two hour movie after season eight to
wrap anything up or do anything that
they don't feel like they have time or
money to do in that final season next
question Ana asks maybe Samwell will
discover how to make Valyrian steel with
all that obsidian a dragon stone yeah I
think that's the ID I mean it seems that
there'd be too much there for them to
take advantage of and even though in the
books
say that the secret of Valyrian steel is
lost the TV show could change that
Samwell could just find some records
buried somewhere right now the citadel
is kind of like the TV shows magic box
that it could pull anything it wants to
out of like oh look here's a record of
Jon Snow's birth oh look here's the
recipe for smelting Valyrian steel so
just expect any number of things to come
out of that storyline but I'm not
expecting a ton of Samwell in season 7 I
think he'll be way more important in
season 8 when they're ready to do like a
big white Walker war for the dawn battle
next question
Shane asks do you think that Tyrians
gonna say anything about Dorne killing
his knees like the Davos Melisandre
moment no I I think that Dorne would be
the one to jump on him the sand snakes
they would probably go a little bit nuts
that they found out he was a Lannister
they're definitely gonna have some fun
with that when they get to Doran but
there's been no evidence the Tyrion
knows that Myrcella is dead so hopefully
Tyrion will be able to charm his way out
of that situation I think that Daenerys
is gonna have to step in and help him
and just like order them to not kill him
on pain of death like I will feed you to
my dragons if you eat my hand next
question William asks why didn't he have
any Targaryen features like silver hair
so there were a lot of people that were
asking this it's just that the stark
features like the really dark hair that
you know the facial features were
dominant over the Targaryen features a
really good example from Star Trek is
half human half Klingons like even if
you have a little bit of Klingon in your
DNA the forehead ridges will stick out
just because Klingon jeans are so much
more dominant over human genes so it's
the same thing with stark features
over-torque iron features and if you
think about it if Jon had been born with
white hair it would have been a dead
giveaway like they're trying to hide the
fact that he's a Targaryen to protect
him next question Terry asks so you
actually have a bunch of questions I'm
just gonna answer this first one because
I think I've answered some of the others
who has left to fight on Circe's side so
the biggest character we have on the
show right now that actually has some
force behind him is Euron remember he
was looking to make an alliance through
marriage so I think that he would offer
that to Cersei just because he's an
even though she probably doesn't want to
get married ever again if you remember
the story of how Davos helped Stannis
out during Robert's rebellion I feel
like we're headed for a similar
situation where the Tyrells cut the food
and grain shipments off from King's
Landing trying to starve them out
remember a lot of the kingdom's food
comes from the
rels so it's really easy for them to
just flip that switch off and try to
starve King's Landing out so Stannis got
trapped in storms end during Robert's
rebellion they were trying to starve him
out but Davos smuggled onions in to feed
Stannis's army even those only onions it
helped them survive to the end of the
war that is why he's called The Onion
Knight
so Euron could become Circe's version of
Davos next question Mike asks what do
you think that Jamie's reaction to
seeing Tyrion and Danny's army will be
do you think that Tyrion will actually
convince him to surrender King's Landing
or do you think that Jamie will have to
kill Cersei in order to give it up I
expect that we'll see some mirrors to
Robert's rebellion and what happened at
the end of that so we might get a queen
Slayer moment but I think that surgery's
gonna make it to the final season I
think if Jaime were to see Tyrion and
all the dragons he would actually
probably be kind of happy for him and
terrified at the same time I mean
anybody would be terrified because you
have a bunch of dragons that want to eat
you for lunch but he doesn't hate his
brother in the way that Cersei does he
actually cares about Tyrians so at the
end of Robert's rebellion after Jaime
killed the Mad King he actually tried to
help his father in Robert's forces get
into the city to try and minimize loss
of life so if they're looking to redeem
TV show Jaime they could have him betray
Cersei in that way
next question Aaron asks could you do a
tourney at Harrenhal in depth video
please yeah there's a whole bunch of
stuff I'll totally do videos for a lot
of the flashbacks I think we'll do
tourney at Harrenhal is a big deal just
because so much was going on there the
really quick version is is that the
tourney of Harrenhal was meant to be
this big celebration but in secret
people believe that Rhaegar organized it
so that all the Lords of the realm would
be there and he could explain his plan
to depose the Mad King while they were
there there was also the incident with
the knight of the Laughing tree and then
obviously the story that Littlefinger
told to Sansa about the crown of blue
roses so you have a lot of socially
scandalous things happening between
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna stark you
also have a lot of political things
going on too and I know a lot of people
would love to see a young Barristan
Selmy remember Barristan Selmy almost
won that tournament
Rhaegar defeated him in the final round
thank you everyone for so many questions
though these are always a ton of fun to
do I'm gonna keep doing them for at
least a couple more weeks so feel free
to leave any questions you guys have
about the season or whatever the bonus
videos end up being each week
congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner - Ben Ayers
you win a $20 Amazon gift card be sure
to private message me on the back end of
my channel so I can get your contact
details that's just on the about page so
my next bonus video will post on Sunday
haven't completely decided what its
gonna be but if there's something
special you guys want me to do just let
me know in the comments like I said most
of my bonus videos during the summer for
Game of Thrones will probably post on
Sundays so why you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn all about why Jon Snow might be
the true king of Westeros and you can
click here for my episode 10 finale
video thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you